[Music]
we are in the basement of Jonathan
Edwards college at the je press je press
has been around since about 1936 so we
are standing in one of the last
remaining undergraduate print shops on
campus
[Music]
the unique feature of this particular
space is that we're practicing
typography essentially as Gutenberg
envisioned it about 600 years ago we are
specifically doing is printing from
handset metal type and up until about
1950 Letterpress was just the way most
things got printed almost every College
had its own printing press and somewhere
in the college that was sort of a
service for students to use so that they
could print like programs for concerts
or like posters for events or their own
stationery or any really anything that
they wanted
you know Letterpress I think it really
is in service of the undergraduate
experience
[Music]
here for mere Amusement sake like it
does provide a practical function within
the life of the college it seems to be a
more enriched form of gift giving you
know this is something that I made and
I'm sharing it with you I think that
that's that really appeals to people
[Music]
the first step of Letterpress printing
anything that's words always starts with
type this is a type case
this is 12 point Centaur and each of
these cases contains one font and a font
is one size and style of a typeface
[Music]
we have about
385 type cases in here in the cabinets
which would be 385 different fonts the
first step to using type is composing
and this is a composing stick and it's
got this adjustable knee here
so you can adjust how
wide your line length is or your measure
say I want to print the line printing
time exclamation points I'm starting
with a capital P I know where that is
and these go upside down left to right
and then they line up with these notches
on the top
every character is upside down but it
reads left to right like normal this is
the process of setting type
here is another example of a set page of
type
this is a little bit fancy I did this
for Valentine's Day
so this is our Vandercook sp20 now we
can ink it up take an ink knife
and we're just going to apply it on
[Music]
now is the fun part I'm gonna turn it on
let this down and then let down the
rollers
I'm going to use two sheets of newsprint
for thickness because it's pretty thin
but first we'll ink the cut
[Music]
set it to print
line the paper up
then when you roll it
and the grippers release at the very end
of the bed
[Applause]
[Music]
the era of Letterpress really wasn't
that long ago and I think allowing
students to participate in it helps
collapse time in a way and connects them
to a deeper tradition
I was a first year in Pearson yeah I
just was curious about it and I signed
up I just kept taking the classes and I
kept just like showing up and it sort of
became my kind of like my evening ritual
throughout all of first year
hey this is beautiful the quality of the
work that people put out after only a
few months of training is really
impressive I think that the constraints
of it being limited by size and the
number of Swords we have in a type case
and time creates such a fertile breeding
ground for people's creativity even if
they don't consider themselves a
particularly creative person being
forced to work in these constraints
produces incredibly imaginative stuff
letterpresses in a way it kind of it
coordinates the the hand The Head and
the Heart in a way that other
disciplines can't really Yale is a place
that you would come to be challenged
intellectually and across various other
academic disciplines the way that
Letterpress forces students to
participate in the craft and really
slows them down but gives them the
agency to pursue their own creative
Ambitions I just think that's a
Priceless opportunity for the right kind
of student
foreign